these very tense moments for dozens
stuck high above the strip technical
issues left passengers up on the high
roller stranded for hours we spoke to
some of those on board to find out what
they went through and through their
minds in those pods
late friday night tourists found
themselves stuck inside the high roller
at the link for hours i spoke to two
passengers from california who were
stuck with 15 others in roller 12. i
noticed it was tilting because i was
sitting down and i started leaning
forward and i turned and looked at her i
was like i don't think this is normal we
were hanging on to the ledge and i like
let it go and i slid all the way to the
bottom we both slid across
the ball the lights then turned off and
for some 9-1-1 calls started half of us
were freaking out half of them were
having like a good time in there and
drinking the person on the other line
when we're communicating to like you
know whoever's doing it said that they
might have to repel us down and after
about two hours the pods steadied and
returned to the ground the girls were
told by high roller employees this has
never happened before it took rosa and
martha some time to calm down it was
like some final destination stuff i'm
not gonna lie
now this isn't the first time people got
stuck up on a strip attraction back in
2005 two teen girls were stranded above
the strat in the extreme they got down
safely after a couple of hours the strat
is about 1100 feet tall double the
highest point on the high roller